yo what's going on guys crispy flakes
here off bleacher report so the 2022 nba
all-star rosters are now set in stone
well at least for the most part but with
that being said it brings up the
question every single season who is the
biggest snub who is one player two
players that totally deserved to make it
but for whatever reason there just
simply was not enough nba all-star
roster spots and they are now listed as
a snow guys let me know in the comment
section below who is the biggest one or
maybe you're somebody that thinks that
the teams are flawless and this is
exactly how it's supposed to be uh but
let's go ahead man and real quick here
do a refresher on the guys that actually
made it then we're gonna go ahead and
talk about those snubs a little bit so
uh yes for the eastern conference stars
as you guys know now demar derozan trey
young giannis cooper joel embiid and
kevin durant uh now kevin durant i
believe is a captain but it's been
announced that he's not going to play in
the game so if one of your favorite
players was a snub there's still a good
chance that they could make it um just
based off of that alone as an injury
replacement there's usually one or two
every single season and then over for
the western stars we know it's john
murray andrew wiggins yoke it's lebron
james steph curry i believe they are all
playing in it as far as i know and here
we go man so we got for the west
all-star reserves we got devon booker
donovan mitchell luka doncic chris paul
rudy gobert draymond green and karl
anthony towns so
yeah as far as this goes i mean in my
opinion all these guys deserve to make
it now i understand with like snubs we
like to say that yeah this guy deserves
to make it over this guy but you know
for the most part all these players are
great and they're very deserving of it
so i try to keep that mindset um you
know as i look at who the biggest snubs
are and everything so yeah no nothing
against any of these guys here man you
got the representation of the phoenix
suns you know we got some great guard
play with devin booker donovan mitchell
you have the defense being represented
with rudy gobert also draymond green so
i mean leadership of cp3 the all-around
game of luca downtrench carlton towns
and kind of the reassurance of the uh
timberwolves like no arguments here
whatsoever um also it is noted too that
draymond green said that he is also not
playing in the game so once again you're
gonna have an eastern conference injury
reserve and also a western conference
injury reserve so um once again if your
favorite player got snubbed there is
still a chance but uh over for the east
all-stars we got jimmy butler we got
zach levine darius garland chris
middleton james harden jason tatum and
fred van vliet who uh fred by the way
man you know being an undrafted player
and working himself to an nba all-star
reserve is absolutely an amazing story
right there's a shout out to him in the
toronto raptor fans uh once again i
cannot complain about any of these guys
i will say maybe that if there was one
that maybe caught me off guard just a
little bit and even that it's a great
player is uh chris middleton um
i mean his name was on my radar as you
know he's a great player former all-star
for the bucks but uh man there was a lot
of talented guys and one thing that i
noticed right away is there's not a
single player for the hornets have that
be either lamello ball or even miles
bridge in this case right so let's go
ahead here hop over to some of the snubs
that are being listed we got three big
ones right here man the one that came to
my mind the most was the jonte murray of
the san antonio spurs this kid is like a
near triple double threat has the
defense and everything um i think it's a
case of
you know there's just so many talented
guards in the nba and uh sometimes for
these young players it takes them a
while before they get the opportunity to
actually get one of those all-star spots
so um you know you recognize the
greatness you see the great play
hopefully in a lot of these cases young
players use it as motivation to continue
being great going forward and get even
better because of it and uh yeah make it
the year after right um then you got
lamela ball of the charlotte hornets
right here too i mean like i was saying
between him and miles bridges i was
hoping one of the guys of the horns
could have made it but uh
wasn't the case and real quick you're
just looking at both of these guys of
the charlotte hornets just kind of see
what they've been doing on this season i
mean i think currently they're seventh
place in the uh eastern conference which
it's been such a close race but both
these guys 20 point regain scores you
got the all-around game of lamela ball
miles bridges has just really stepped up
as a guy that you know last season
towards the end of the year he was
putting up really solid numbers but it
wasn't really leading to wins or
anything so now you have a case where
well this horns team is very competitive
too so you would hope that uh that would
have got recognized as far as uh you
know the coaches and everything voting
these guys in but yeah no representation
for the charlotte hornets which is not
totally fun to see um but also we got
another guy right here in jalen brown so
jaylen brown being snubbed which brings
up so many interesting aspects and i
will say
if there is a guy that is to replace
kevin durant assuming they're going by
the forward formula then i'm saying you
probably move jason tatum or jimmy
butler to that starter spot and maybe a
guy like jaylen brown gets in there
because uh once again let's take a look
at jaylen brown as he compares to like a
jason tatum um i mean jason's a guy
that's in the game right so yeah this is
gonna be uh quite interesting to look at
jason tatum
i mean the scoring roughly the same
assist roughly the same rebounds roughly
the same you look at the overall
shooting performances and collectively
speaking i mean jalen brown is even
shooting better than jason tatum we also
know jaylen brown's a great defensive
player in his own right so i mean yeah i
think that's definitely in my opinion
just as far as just guys that have been
in the nba and just like hey like this
guy deserves to make it jaylen brown is
my biggest snub in my opinion man but uh
yes uh let me know in the comment
section below who do you think the
biggest one is of all
i think these all-star reserves are
pretty dang perfect in my opinion i
guess just one last comparison because i
was talking about chris middleton so
let's get a uh
quick look at him too man just like as
it compares to like jalen brown who did
not make it right so
i mean scoring jalen brown assists a
little bit chris middleton rebounds
jaylen brown overall efficiency jaylen
brown so yeah this is why it kind of
surprised me a little bit right there
with him
but i guess real quick here too we can
go to the season leaders uh we'll just
look at points per game because that's
typically a pretty good indicator of
talent and just see if there's anybody
else on this list here that pops out as
a guy that did not make it but you look
at all the top scorers um they're all
represented so
yeah it looks like the first one that's
not would be bradley beal the washington
wizards had a slow start to the season
been playing better as of late but the
wizards have not so that's kind of a
weird correlation right there uh you got
shea gil just alexander i just think
it's a case of the thunder not really
playing the greatest basketball you got
brandon ingram who's you know big been a
big leader
for the pelicans this season was zion
not playing um i know i had some people
talk about me earlier saying that you
know like andrew wiggins has not been as
good this season as brandon ingram but
my argument with wiggins is that wiggins
is an all-star in the type of role that
he plays and it leads to success for the
golden state warriors as opposed to
ingram who is great like i'm not denying
how good ingram is uh let's actually
pull this up on the comparison real
quick here man real quick here just
because i think it's such an interesting
topic and kind of uh
a good way to view how you know we view
nba all-stars and everything right man
because
um you know it's all about excitement
and everything but also winning
basketball games i think is also
important in the role you play and how
you help your team do so so while the
numbers lean towards ingram you know
wiggins also is a great defensive player
um just wiggins playing that third
option role behind you know steph curry
and klay thompson man he's been an
all-star in his own right doing that
it's led to great success so
love seeing that but beyond that um you
know you got anthony edwards yo james
harden yeah james harden didn't make it
okay i was like james harden made it
right
uh anthony edwards it's nice seeing uh
timberwolf get representation in carlos
from the towns ant-man will definitely
get there eventually fred van vleet got
that's nice dear fox pascal siacom you
know him um
sabonis you could talk about those guys
a little bit too but the raptors do got
representation with fred van fleet
that's nice uh sabonis has made it in
the past pacers have not been all that
great so not really too upset there i
would say overall
these are nailed for the most part you
know there's probably exceptions that
you could debate about but uh yeah man
this is pretty good what do you guys
think man let me know in the comments
explore your biggest nba all-star snub
thank you all so much for watching and
peace out my friends